>> BURCH: Hi, my name is Todd Burch and I’m
one of the partners of smustard.com. Back
in 2003, when I was a professional wood worker,
I needed a 3D design program. And, I did the
search and I found SketchUp and I started
using it, and it was great. But I could--I
knew I could do more if SketchUp had an API.
And about a year later, in 2004, it was SketchUp
Version 4. SketchUp came out with an API implemented
in Ruby. I didn’t know Ruby at that time
but I sat down and learned it, and that just
really took SketchUp to the next level for
me. After writing scripts for the user community,
and for several years, I partnered with Rick
Wilson and Octavian Chis and we formed Smustard,
and our goal for smustard.com is to provide
scripts to the user community that will make
them more productive just like they were more
productive for us.
>> MALE: So can you talk about how you chose
the SketchUp API, and tell us a little bit
about how you came to this technical decision?
And what was it about it that made you think
this is what I'm going to develop for?
>> BURCH: Yeah, when the Ruby API came out
with SketchUp, I knew there was an opportunity
there to speed my use of SketchUp up. And
so, learning the Ruby API and learning how
to code in Ruby enabled to me to be more productive
to use these SketchUp. And so, instead of
sitting down and maybe drawing a cabinet and
taking 30 minutes to do it, you know, I sat
down for a couple of hours and I wrote a script
that would draw a cabinet and the next time
I need to draw a cabinet, it takes five seconds.
So it really made me a lot more productive.
>> MALE: As developers, we really value being
able to share war stories and lessons from
technical challenges? Can you tell us about
one particularly difficult period of development
that you faced and how you approach this technical
challenge?
>> Sometimes, as developer, you run in to
technical challenges when using a product
or an API. One specific technical challenge
or a series of technical challenges that I’ve
had over the years were more related to advanced
math concepts that I never had in school,
for instance, transformations, scaling and
rotations. And so, learning to go through
and how to implement--not just use the API
but figure out what those math concepts were
to be able to manipulate things in an advance
way when inside SketchUp was kind of challenging.
But the user community, the other scriptors
and even the Google people were just wonderful
helping us users learn how to use the product.
>> MALE: So, tell me some of your favorite
features in SketchUp, in SketchUp API?
>> BURCH: My favorite features with the SketchUp
API, first and foremost, is that it’s implemented
in the Ruby language. You know, when the Ruby
language was chosen by Joe Esch, one of the
original authors of SketchUp, Ruby was a new
language. And not many people knew Ruby, and
since 2002 or 2003 whenever he decided to
implement Ruby as the language, Ruby is now
very well-known for Web development, and not
as many people use it for just applications.
So SketchUp is using Ruby as an application
programming language, scripting language.
And so, a lot of people that have grown up
around Ruby think of it as rails but this
is not rails, this is just a Ruby language.
And so, it’s been a really good thing.
>> MALE: What are some things that you’d
like to see added to the SketchUp API, the
future of what you see implemented?
>> BURCH: As far as the future of SketchUp
and the Ruby API, some of the things that
we would like to see at smustard.com is-is-is
better support for getting the word out that
there are these things called extensions,
and letting the user community know that they’re
pretty easy to implement and giving the users
an easy way to bring those in to SketchUp.
I mean, we don’t want anybody to have to
learn how to be a programmer or even mess
with their file systems. So we would like
to see better support for distribution and
installation of Ruby scripts.
>> MALE: And what do you see as the future
of 3D?
>> BURCH: You know, as far as the future of
SketchUp and 3D modeling, you know, SketchUp’s
goal in the beginning was 3D for every one.
And I think they've come a long way towards
that--I mean, there’s a lot of big players
in the market place that are doing 3D that
have a very well-established user base. And
so, SketchUp is coming up and, you know, it’s
always kind have been--I don’t want to say
the joke of industry but it’s like, “Oh
well, you know, it’s free. How could it
be productive for people?” But, you know,
the SketchUp community is very alive and very
well and SketchUp users are growing everyday.
So I think the future is going to bring more
people using SketchUp and more people moving
off of their legacy solutions and using SketchUp,
and part of that, is going to mean extensions
of SketchUp to customize SketchUp for their
processing, and to integrate SketchUp into
their flow of business that they’re establishing
using it today.
>> MALE: Great. Thank you very much.
>> BURCH: Okay.